high up in the Cordillera mountains in
the philippines in the village of boosts
:
lives a woman who is the last of her
kind girl national later canoe we shall
look even hotter
[Music]
my barber talk is the name given to the
traditional tattoo artists of the
Kalinga ethnic group the artists are
masters of their thousand-year-old trade
originally giving tattoos to warriors
who won in battle in shadowy yuki-chan a
chicken piccata shyaa'n learn with Ruth
Marie Ragnar Sharon Sharon hi a new key
will converge to new photo okay buddy
Tony bolado every year thousands of
tourists make the journey to see Wang on
and get one of her famous tattoos
[Music]
mushiya notice a night a funny a
poly-rayon pooja we channel patty happy
Satan and Louis Sachar share sad iesson
jato
triple-teaming yo-chan
yeah be a revolution
I don't aim you know hotter forever if
you're burnin even my colleague Wang out
is now the last month avatar but she's
teaching her granny's to carry on the
family tree
Johanna - Jesse yoga in Ankara
[Music]